il était amarré depuis près de cinq
jours dans la rade du port turc de
karasu mais ce cargo russe a pu
finalement quitté les eaux turques
direction la russie et le port de quatre
cases
inacceptable pour kiev qui accuse le
bateau de transporter des céréales
ukrainienne volée nous regrettons que le
navire russe du bec jolly qui était
rempli de céréales l'ukrainienne volet
était autorisé à quitter le port de
carras sous malgré l'épreuve criminelles
présenté aux autorités turques
l'ambassadeur de turquie à kiev sera
convié au ministère des affaires
étrangères pour clarifier cette
situation inacceptable
selon les autorités ukrainiennes le
navire est parti de berne y ans situé en
territoire ukrainien sous contrôle russe
avant d'arriver en turquie vendredi
dernier et repartir ce mercredi soir
vers la russie
immédiatement l'ambassade d'ukraine
avait demandé à la turquie de l'arrêter
et de l'inspecter
car selon kiev 7000 tonnes de céréales
obtenues illégalement seraient stockés à
son bord des accusations fausses selon
la russie qui a confirmé que des
contrôles turcs ont eu lieu sur le
bateau ce mercredi de son côté ankara
reste muet sur ses intentions depuis le
début de la faire
la turquie est considéré comme une
alliée de l'ukraine mais veillent tout
de même à garder une position neutre
envers la russie l'un de ses principaux
fournisseurs en énergie